I think Andrew is amazing for men I  think right now there are no male role  models of course as Jordan Peterson  who's amazing but he's not going to  relate to the young boy so I think he's  absolutely amazing the tons of messages  that I've received from young boys just  saying thank you so much for supporting  him he's saved my life he's done all  these amazing things and I think he  might be extreme to some standards  however he's allowing the pendulum to  move the other way Society went so the  other way it went so liberal and so woke  that we actually need a Crazy Character  like Andrew to bring us back to  normality and I think even he would  admit hopefully men will end somewhere  in the middle more to his side obviously  but end somewhere in the middle